biden rolls out a policy  which is you have 100 employees  you've got to vaccinate or you've got a  test weekly no mandated masking for the  unvaccinated  fox's on-air talent  goes on and says this is tyrannical this  is not freedom this is un-american this  must be stopped this could be against  the law and yet behind the scenes  fox news has the same vaccinator test  requirement except at fox it's not a  weekly test it's a daily test if you're  unvaccinated and in addition to that in  some settings if you're unvaccinated you  have to keep wearing a mask it is much  stricter at fox news than what fox's own  on-air talent decries as tyrannical  government oppression  uh as outlined by joe biden in his  proposal so why hasn't tucker carlson  resigned to protest these dystopian  policies